we're talking today to our president
chris holden chris you've been president
for two years how have you seen the
organization grow and develop in that
time well it's been an exciting time
it's particularly exciting for me as
president and what we've seen is the
membership of the five-day home council
has been growing which is showing a lot
more interest we've seen five to the
home growing as well within europe
and we've also seen the council itself
doing much more participation and
interaction with the key players that
are actually going to be driving fibre
home in the future yes i mean fdt-8 is
really out there now isn't it it's not a
theory it's actually getting in there
yes it's certainly getting in there
and we see from our figures for instance
in europe now there are 4.6 million
subscribers which is an increase of
nearly 26 percent
in russia there's 5.6 million mostly
five to the building because they have
very large buildings and there's 0.3
million in middle east
and and with within europe do you see
the eu digital agenda helping that
acceleration
yes certainly i mean the digital agenda
put a target of 100 megabits for the
first time which is a great target for
everybody to aim at and national
governments have to have plans to try
and meet that target as well so that's
and 100 megabits let's be honest it's
going to be fiber to the home that is
really the only true future-proof
solution for 100 megabits service but
it's also driving western europe because
western europe to meet this target means
they have to grow out five at home and
they've been a little lacks in doing
that at the moment
principally because they're saying is a
really good business case for this and
the business case revolves around
customers take-up and customer take-up
revolves around services
yes now you know we also think that
there's going to be tremendous new
services but what are they
well there will be new services and this
is a chicken-and-egg situation in a way
because you need an infrastructure in
place to be able to develop the new
services and that's certainly going to
happen because we see everything
expanding
but existing services also require five
little homes so if you truly have a
proper e-health service for instance
then that's going to help and that would
also help national governments in their
spending but then there's e-learning so
for villages and remote areas children
can have much better education and then
there's business so people who work from
home
like myself need good bandwidth to be
able to send files back and forth and
truly work that way now i think you're
going to try and uh show people what you
mean in munich in february with the
world of applications at your event tell
us a bit about that yes we're quite
excited about that actually so that's
going to be at our munich conference
and we're excited because we're actually
going to show services and services
basically will exist so you'll be able
to come out of a plenary session walk
onto a big mezzanine floor and see those
services there interact with those
services and hopefully everybody that
sees them says yes this is really the
future and we want some of this which
will help drive five into the home
but not only that that's part of our
conference
last year we had three thousand people
it was the largest five to home
conference in the world
we already expect to have more than that
in munich we have more sponsors it's
going to be a really exciting event
just so you know and everybody else
don't forget 14th to the 16th of
february munich's the date we hope
you'll be there and we hope lots more
people also join us okay well thanks for
talking to us you're welcome brian thank
you